[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
NANCY HACHISU: Thank you.
So as Sonya said, I
have two other books.
This is my third book.
A lot of people Google me.
And they think, oh,
you're the farm girl.
And they write me
this email and say,
can I come stay at your farm?
I'm like, no, please no.
I mean, I actually
haven't been able to--
I was never the farm girl.
I grew up in Atherton.
[LAUGHTER]
OK.
Let's just be real.
And I did what I could,
because my husband
was a chicken farmer.
And say, I wanted
to eat the chickens.
So he has to kill--
or chicken.
And he has to kill it for me.
And then so I should
be the one to clean it.
And I've never done it before.
But that was how I got into--
and we were also kind of
beatnik types in Atherton.
So it was not so, so
different approach wise.
But I tried really hard
on the farm helping out.
He never sold vegetables.
It was just for the family.
Also, he grows rice and
wheat for the family.
And we have three children,
have a little home businesses,
out of school.
I was teaching cooking.
And so I just did what I
could as the Atherton girl
who had not the
strength of character
as this farm husband of mine.
And time went along.
I was also trying to do an
edible schoolyard type thing.
It's really difficult with
three and four-year-olds,
because they run
all over the field.
They smash the little
lettuce seedlings.
And they scatter
the seeds like that.
But I just kept trying.
And then I had wanted
to write a cookbook.
I was thinking I was going to
write a cookbook about my food.
My husband was doing all
the Japanese cooking.
I did some.
I've been cooking
since I was a kid.
And I thought the easiest entrée
into publishing was in Japan,
because that's where
my contacts were.
But I started taking
online classes at Stanford
to get back my writing.
And people told me
to start a blog.
And I heard of this.
And so one of my
friends said just
check David Lebovitz's
blog, which I did.
And there was this blog
camp, which I went to.
David recommended, he said--
use me as an example.
If you're living on an
organic Japanese farm,
then you should write
a book about niche.
You should write a book about
the 100 best farm recipes.
So I was like, OK.
I was going to write that
book after my little book.
But I guess everybody
wants the Japanese book.
Well in fact, I was collecting
books, because that was my--
I'm always looking
ahead very many years.
I already have the next
few books mapped out.
But I have never
really seen a book
that I wanted to cook
from in Japanese cooking.
I do have [INAUDIBLE]
and things like that.
Actually, I haven't
looked at his books.
And he's probably a good
example of somebody to go to.
But there was a lot
of women's cooking.
And it was not really
appealing to me.
We drink wine, or beer, or
sake, which are not tea.
I wasn't looking for sweet
foods or little stylized foods
that you have to buy all these
things at the supermarket from.
This is not what we ate.
And so I was always
intending to write--
and also, I like a
more direct food.
And so I intended to
write a book of my--
on my [INAUDIBLE] pages
for Stanford I would say,
I'm going to write the book
of this, and this, and this.
When Japanese men
cook was the thing.
And I do that to keep
myself motivated.
OK, five years from now
I will have this book.
But it took a few reunions
before it actually
materialized.
And I had another friend,
the soba guy, soba chef guy.
And I just loved
their food so much.
There were different foods.
But in the end, I wrote
a book about our food,
my husband's food, Kanchan's
food, and then my food,
because I had never even
made nikujaga, frankly,
which is a so standard dish.
And I was chasing my husband.
Tadaaki, Tadaaki, how
do you make nikujaga?
He'd say, OK, this much meat,
and this much onions, and glug,
glug, glug soy sauce,
and some ginger,
and simmer it for 15
minutes, and blah.
So I did it.
I got all the stuff all ready.
And then I used what I
thought was the right amount
and then measured it after
how much I actually used.
And that became the recipe.
And it was perfect the first
time and better than his.
[LAUGHTER]
Which we don't say
in front of him.
And he doesn't watch
these, so no problem.
Though some of his
friends do and report in.
It's really kind of bad.
I wrote more, and
more, and more recipes.
Each project, whether it's
a book or it's a meal,
it gels at some point.
And then it shoop, like that.
So you approach it
thinking, OK, I'm
going to organize the book,
or the project, like this.
Then you don't
want to step on it
too much, because
then you're messing
with the creative part of it.
And then finally,
it just makes sense.
And then you can actually
do the nuts and bolts of it.
And that happened
with each book.
I considered regionality
for the first two books.
For the preserving book, I was
really intending to separate it
regionally and seasonally.
No.
We were talking
about seasonality,
forget the regionality.
I considered seasonality
for the first two books.
And it became too
difficult, because carrots
were all year round.
Komatsuna is the green
leaves, all year round.
And preserving was made
sense to be seasonally.
But there's the summer.
And there's winter.
And then some of those
vegetables go both ways.
So it made much
more sense that I
wrote a book about
where I organized it
through the mediums, the
preserving, or pickling,
mediums.
And also by then, I was
visiting the makers.
It was intended that I had
a small budget for that
from the publishers,
a production budget I
didn't have to pay back.
But then at the same time, I was
contacted by Fuji Television.
Now I can ask for payment,
but not very much.
But basically with
TV, they think
they're doing you a favor.
But they paid some of the
expenses for the travel.
And that was very helpful.
And also, it opens
doors, because you say,
oh, I want to come visit you.
And I want to find out
all this information.
And if it's for TV, they're
like, yeah, sign me up.
But if it's a book that they'll
see maybe three years from now,
I mean, now I know them.
And so it's fine.
But there was some
issues with this book.
The politicians
were all excited.
I have a friend in the
prime minister's office.
And he said, oh, all these guys
in the prefectural government,
they got really excited
when I told them
about this book
you're doing, Nancy.
And they want to share
their local recipes.
And then when we really
got down to the fact
that, well, it's
coming out in 2018,
and this was in
2015, like, what?
Well, they won't be
in office anymore.
So we'll forget that one.
OK.
So it was really hard to--
I had to pay all the travel
and photography, which
that's another story.
So I set up for this book.
So that was my life.
I wrote about our
life, our friends.
I also wanted to write about
what I felt was the real Japan,
or the Japan I
knew, because people
love to tell these stories about
how Japanese are so mysterious.
Oh, there's all sorts
of weird adjectives.
But I mean, I just find
you can hug people.
You can do whatever you
want, except for there's
some foreign things people do
like, I mean, the shoe thing.
Or I don't like to take big,
foreign men into antique shops,
because they bang things around.
But there's a part of
Japan that a lot of people
don't quite understand.
And that's the
relationship issues.
And that comes into play
with asking for things.
There's an inherent
responsibility
about how you ask,
what you give back.
And also, I've
occasionally been contacted
by some filming people.
And me introducing
somebody to them,
there's a huge responsibility
on my part as the introducer.
But otherwise, I mean,
Japanese people wise,
we're all the same
all over the world.
We have some other differences.
So that's what I wanted to show.
And also, frankly, I mean,
some of the cookbook authors
tell you, oh, every Japanese
has every color on the table.
It's white.
It's black.
It's green.
It's red.
Which is just bullshit.
And I'm sorry.
They don't.
And they don't have
sweet, and sour,
and all these food tastes
on the table every day.
Everybody is just scrambling
to get the food on the table.
Most likely they're buying it
at the supermarket or 7-Eleven,
big way of life there.
So people are just
trying their best.
And cooking is down
all over the world.
We all know that.
And the Japanese government
is super worried about it
in Japan.
But the great thing
about Japan is
things change really quickly,
because if something happens
in the media or
something happens here,
and then you can take a second
look at their own country.
And that's actually
the great thing
of living in a small country,
because the US is this morass--
it's like this frigate.
How do you move that frigate
from its decided course?
And actually I was just in
Malibu at a pop-up I did.
And this very famous surfer,
who I don't know the name,
said to me--
he's Japanese.
And he said, I give your
"Japanese Farm Food" book
to so many friends when I want
to say this is Japanese food
that I want.
I mean, he also has a
little organic garden.
This is the food that I
think is Japanese food.
And this is the way Japan is.
And so that was a huge
compliment actually.
That was just recently.
But then I wrote
the preserving book.
A lot of it was research,
and also from friends,
from the makers,
various sources.
And basically, I
wanted it to be--
it was six months
late turning in,
because there was
so much I found.
And I felt like,
I'm not going to be
writing another preserving
book for God knows when.
And so this is my chance to
put in methods that actually I
did once, I mean, if you
could think about it.
And so I put them in as
methods, not recipes.
And OK, fermentation geeks,
they can just give it a go,
and use your brains, and
work it out yourself.
But if you imagine
a preserving book,
you get one chance at ume,
the sour, so-called, plum.
Or there's really
one small window
for doing semi-dry daikon
and those type of pickles.
And so it's in December.
You can fudge it.
But you don't get a lot
of chances at these.
And especially, it takes
a few months for something
to actually become the
preserve it's supposed to be.
And then oops, and
then what do you do?
So it was a little bit panicky.
But this book, I
got asked to do it.
Phaidon doesn't take
pictures, they ask you.
And it's part of
a country series.
And you guys are
probably too young,
but the Time Life series
is a famous country series.
I think they're trying
to jump into that slot.
It started out with a very
famous Italian cookbook
that's, in English
they translated it,
called "The Silver Pot Palate."
it was a big, big
seller in Italy
and then a huge seller here.
And then they did the
same with a French one.
And then they segued into
asking an author in country.
And then finally, they started
naming it blah, blah, blah,
the cookbook.
And I think they're renaming
some of the older books.
And I was a little
scared, because I was just
taking a little sabbatical from
my first publisher, who now
doesn't do my books anymore.
So I've moved on to another one.
They have a new CEO.
And they're trying
to make money.
So they're doing YA
and some weird poetry
that I know is really--
I shouldn't even say it, because
I don't know anything about it.
But I guess YA is big
and poetry something.
You probably all know it,
because it's a big seller.
And anyway, so I was very
disciplined about this book.
And I had signed the
contract 2015, winter.
So I had two years to
two and a half years
to do it, two years to do it.
And I separated the
country out into--
I don't even have
a watch either.
Hey, Max, can you
give me my phone?
Thanks.
I separated the
country out to places
where I knew chefs,
because you can pay someone
to cook for you.
That's a concept.
And that's the easiest way.
That was the easiest entrée.
And the chefs know
the local people.
And they know the artisans.
And so I started to
travel to these places.
These photos are
not in the book.
We'll pick that up later.
My idea was I was going
to go two to three times,
then take the photographer
the last time,
and developing the
relationship before bringing
the photographer.
And I wished I could
have gone more.
But that's the max on
my personal budget.
So I did find that, again,
without the camera, some
of the people, like
the fisherman lady,
actually didn't want to do the
cooking thing for me again.
And they had with the camera.
Some other local ladies did.
And then some of the
ladies were like, oh, yeah.
They would sit around the table.
And we're drinking tea.
And they'd be telling
me and the chef
about all these local
foods that they make.
And oh, yeah, but they
make them at New Year
or at Obon in the summer.
And what am I going to say?
Can I come next time?
And can you cook for me?
But I was gathering material.
And then I was photographing
the chef's food
and organizing the book.
I had to make a
decision pretty much
not to do Hokkaido and
Okinawa, because they were off
of Honshu.
But I included Kyushu and
had a lot of material.
But then my photographer quit.
And I hired another guy.
And Phaidon didn't particularly
like that guy for some reason.
I don't know why.
And so all these
photos were out.
And I've repurposed
them with another book,
"Food Artisans of Japan" book,
for Hardie Grant in Australia.
And I had to rethink, OK, how
will I organize this book now
without--
there's no stories, no photos.
There was like
seven in the book.
And the food photography
was done in New York.
And around that
time, or before that,
before that I was going
to put a little section
in the back of some of
the Frenchy Japanese food,
which is super cool.
And the Italiany Japanese food,
because a lot of the chefs
I know aren't doing
Japanese food.
They're doing
French and Italian.
But it's not really
One of the guys said
to me, you know,
Nancy, the reason why
this group of chefs
can do this food, this
Italian or this French food,
is because we're approaching it
through our Japanese culinary
roots.
And so we're bringing the
techniques and the flavors
into French and Italian food.
And so that's what makes it,
he's not going to say special.
But for me, that's
what makes it special.
I mean, maybe he's going to say
that's what makes it unique.
I mean, they're using dashi.
There's a lot of clarity
in Japanese food.
And so if you think
about it, I mean,
frankly, I think that some of
the Japanese French and Italian
food is better than what
I've had in France and Italy.
But anyway, I was going to
put some shojin ryori in there
too in the back section.
And I know this Zen nun,
known her for years.
And again, it was a situation
of how do I ask her?
And she lives in Okayama,
which is near Kyoto.
And I live near Tokyo, well
an hour on the bullet train.
How do I ask her to cook for me?
I mean, it's a really
hard thing to do.
And I don't really know
what the situation is.
Well it turns out, and
I saw her a few times.
And finally, the
second time, there
is this ceremony
at Meigi Jingu I
go to every or every
other year, where
the guy cuts down the
[? carp ?] without touching it
with this massive knife.
It looks like it
can't cut anything.
But I guess it must
be like a katana.
And the guy's 34th
generation Shijo.
I forget his first
name, ex rock drummer.
And he's the head of this
family, Shijo family,
that is one of the protectors
of Japanese cuisine.
And they've got a street named
after him in Kyoto, Shijo-dori.
It's the one with the little
river on it, really pretty.
Anyway, so I approached
her at that second one.
And I asked her, I was
kind of feeling her out,
on how to cook [INAUDIBLE].
And she said, oh, I
can do it any time.
I could come to your
house, or you could come.
So I really pinned
her down on it.
And she wrote me this fax,
because she was not super--
I know she has a smartphone.
And she does some really
short, little emails.
But she sent me a
fax, a long fax,
explaining about the situation.
She cooks at two temples.
She doesn't live
there, they're Zen,
because the men priests
are in residence.
And they just eat Japanese food.
And because they don't
really have a big budget,
they don't eat the
greatest Japanese food.
The katsuobushi is the
little, tiny packages.
But she has a really
beautiful feel of her food.
And anyway, I was there.
And then it turns out she cooked
a whole shojin lunch for me,
just for me, not even for her.
And it's quite a big--
it's the temple food.
There's just a whole prescribed
amount of dishes and placement.
But she was excited
about the whole thing.
And I was planning to come back
for each season in planning
for the future for
our shojin ryori book
that I will be doing, hopefully.
And I brought the
photographer once.
But anyway, on that
first trip, she
gave me this book
that she had written
before she'd become a nun.
It was called something,
"Kenko Ryori," healthy cooking.
We didn't have that.
We had her temple food book.
And I handed it to my--
I'm a very lazy Japanese reader,
writer, reader and writer.
And I handed it to my son,
Andrew, who was in between jobs
and just doing this
all day long, which
is really irritating, because
I didn't grow up with that.
And I hate it.
And so I give him the book.
And he's got a good palate.
He used to work
for the soba guy.
And I gave him the book.
And I said, Andrew,
can you help me?
Can you please do something?
Because also I was feeding him.
And his father was doing
his laundry, not me.
And I gave him a little
stack of Post-its.
And the book is this big.
I think there's
260 recipes in it.
And I said, could you
just mark anything
that looks really delicious?
And so eventually, I don't
know how long it took him.
I got the book back.
And it had 100 marks in it.
And I was really excited.
And so I sat down with
one of my ex-students,
who was interning
for me in the summer.
And again, I cook
for the students.
And so they're all
fairly food oriented.
And I know his mom cooks too.
And he's a local kid.
He was in high school and
on his way to university.
And we sat down together,
because, like I said,
I'm a lazy Japanese reader.
Also, the beauty of this
book, it had recipes but not--
I mean, just list
up of ingredients
and then a really loose method.
I mean, publishers
now, they want
to know how many minutes
for every single thing.
And she would give like,
it should taste like this.
And she'd give an example.
And I sat down with Keigo.
And we went through the titles,
and they were also really
unusual titles, the titles and
then what was in each thing.
And we were just like, wow.
And we went through
the whole book.
Have you ever had that before?
No.
Doesn't that sound good?
Oh, yeah.
And so we were both
really excited about this.
Yeah, I want to eat that too.
And so starting August
1st, in earnest, I just--
oh, I asked my assistant
to record the book,
because I didn't want
to miss anything.
And August 1st, I started
just madly writing recipes,
no proportions yet.
I was just listing
up the ingredients
and the general method.
And I was going
from the recording
on one of my old phones.
And then I was just
getting a little bit
bored with listening to
the voice all the time.
And so I just started reading.
And that was a big
takeaway for that,
because all of the cool material
is in out-of-print books.
Japanese internet started, I
mean, the use of the internet
started very late.
I got to say 10 years
ago or something,
I mean, they have their
phones, but where everybody's
got a computer in their house.
And so what you find
on Japanese internet,
by and large, is Cookpad,
which is the worst recipes.
It's so horrible.
I mean, English Cookpad is
probably a little bit better,
maybe they curate it.
I don't know.
I've looked before
for something.
And the most astounding mismatch
and mismatched ingredients,
I've never seen a set
of worse ingredients.
But I did meet the guy at
one of the Stanford classes.
And he was super nice.
So I'm sorry.
But I think that people
like to eat like that.
It's just not my thing.
I was looking for authentic,
but interesting, recipes.
So I already wrote two books.
And so I didn't want to repeat.
And so a large portion of
the material in this book
was from [INAUDIBLE].
That was sort of the
unifying force of the book.
And then one of the first places
I'd gone on my research trips
was to Iwate.
There's a really cool chef,
who does Frenchy food.
But he came from
another prefecture.
His wife's from that area.
And he just is so amazingly--
he moved up to this little town.
Then it was hit by the tsunami.
And he took over.
He redid the school
food program.
He's promoting the
fishermen lady's seaweed.
And they sent me some
to take on my tour.
And I've done it before.
And he's really helping
out the local people.
And that's the kind of
people I want to write about,
that kind of a chef or
that kind of an artisan.
And he also does this
food gathering every March
and August.
I've gone a couple
times in March.
And the main cook
is this woman named
Teiko Watanabe,
who I mortifyingly
wrote as Taiko in the book.
She, luckily, will
never read it.
But I will fix it.
It's just, I don't know what
was going on in my head.
But Teiko-san, she feels
like she's six feet tall.
I'm 5' 6".
She must be like 5' 10",
which is really unusual.
She must be 85 now.
And she's a very powerful
but gentle woman.
As a person, she
really attracted me.
And her food was not
necessarily my type of food.
But this is not supposed
to be a Nancy Hachisu book.
I wanted to get food that was
delicious, but not my food.
But I was filming her
on my different devices,
and photographing,
and recording,
and noting, noting, noting.
And then I had
all this material.
I have so many
notebooks of material.
But then, oh, I
have this collection
of Japanese cookbooks, and of
Japanese-Japanese, and then
Japanese in English, and
Japanese people in English,
and then foreigners, like
me, like you, in English
all from the 80s.
And one of the books--
and then Andrew, by then, was
working for me, my second son.
And he comes to
work at 8 o'clock.
And he drinks coffee
for two hours.
He needs a job.
OK.
So Andrew, please,
check these books
and see which ones
look delicious.
But he's good with the kids.
And he's a good cook.
So he, oh, this is shit.
No, no, no, no.
And then finally,
he finds one book.
And it was the one book
that I thought was good too.
And Teiko Watanabe's Japanese
spelling of her name,
it's not self-evident.
And so my assistant said
it was Watabe and then
another first name.
But eventually figured out, oh,
that book that I really like
is Teiko Watanabe's book.
So I call her up through
somebody else and get the OK.
Can I use some of your
recipes, and maybe
fresh them up, and
maybe de-sugarize them,
and use [INAUDIBLE]
or less sweet?
And she said, sure.
And so those two
powerful, beautiful women
made this book what it is.
And then I filled out
with other material
that I had looked at to possibly
include in the other books.
And at the time, I mean, those
are super dated cookbooks.
But looking through
different eyes,
looking through the
eyes of '70s, '80s,
and a whole different style
of food than I had been making
and channeling, I could re-see,
ah, this looks interesting.
And if we just fix
it up a little bit,
it will be super
good for the book.
And so that's how
it all emerged.
Phaidon, they say
it's the Bible Series,
which is a ridiculous idea
in that it's so hard to--
I wonder if they're
going to see this?
Sorry.
It's a great series.
No, it's so hard to
capture the whole cuisine
of a country in 400 recipes.
I had 350 as the minimum.
And I was personally capping
it at 400, because as it was,
it was madness.
I mean, if you could
imagine testing
400 recipes in the space
of, May, June, July, August,
four months.
I almost hated it.
It was just so much.
But the little preschoolers
enjoyed the testing.
I'd say, who wants a taste?
And they'd run, run,
run, run, run, run.
And they loved everything.
And the grandmas and grandpas
who came to pick them up
loved everything.
And my assistant, who's
fiftyish, I don't know, I mean,
she kept saying it was
so beautiful tasting.
And that was how
she liked to eat.
She's not a very good--
She doesn't cook that much.
But she likes that.
There's some shojin
roots in it, the temple,
because actually that's
how Japan was cooking.
That's the history
of Japanese food.
And so it makes a lot of sense.
There's plenty of
meat and fish too.
There's a lot of sesame.
And there's this amazing sesame
roaster in Osaka, Wadaman.
And he donated to me.
He always donates
to me, sesame oils,
I mean, white, gold, black.
The sesame production in
Japan is totally gone,
because it's
outsourced to China.
So he buys his sesame
through contract farmers
from three different countries.
But it's in the roasting.
I mean, of course, the
farmer is an important part.
But the roastery is where
the sesame, just like coffee,
becomes transformed into
this beautiful product.
And some of the
places that I've been
doing pop-ups, the sesame
that's in other kitchens
is most likely rancid.
It's just horrible.
So the Japanese Pantry has it.
And they also donated
a bunch of stuff.
But the sesame was
life-changing and the ume.
OK, it's in the Bible Series.
But it really is a
moment in time in Japan.
And for that way,
it makes sense.
And for me, that was a
great moment in time,
because they were sort
of bubble years of Japan.
It was after the 50s, 60s,
because the war really
decimated the food situation.
And people were just scrambling.
And finally, food was
coming into Japan.
And there was a prosperity.
And so that was a time-- and
it's not farm food, per se.
It's not farm food.
It's maybe more town food
or some seaside food.
But I think it's really
exciting and cool food
and made me re-excited
about Japanese food.
So I stand behind it.
So that's all I've
got right now.
And if you have any
questions, I'm happy to ask.
I need some water.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a little bit
about your creative process.
And at the point where
everything kind of came
together, and took on
its own creative force,
and just became the book,
how much do you think--
I mean, either tracing
back to your visits
to build those
relationships, did
you feel like those
visits to build
those relationships and
those followup visits,
did it actually shape this
whole creative process
later on when it actually
did take on its own force?
NANCY HACHISU: Yes and no.
I mean, most of that material
is going into another book,
because of the photos.
I mean, you always
are getting something
from those visits and
those relationships.
They deepened my understanding
or feeling of the ingredients.
But here, this ended up to
be more research-oriented,
which I think a lot of
the country books are,
because the authors have
to pay for their travel.
But I don't ever
regret the money
spent on creating relationships,
because those are continuing.
And I've been introducing
those people to other people.
Like, there's this
amazing potato flour
that they are making in that
town that has 3,000 people
and that was hit by the tsunami.
I think there's one guy
in Japan making this.
And I don't like to tell
too many people about it.
And I guess I shouldn't
say it on this venue.
But it's this flour.
And I used it at a
dinner in San Francisco.
And everybody went crazy for it.
It's a flour made from potatoes
and this amazing process
of drying them outside.
And you can use it for--
in the local area, they make
little manju or little dango.
And they're not so
delicious or interesting.
They're little flour balls.
But he used it to make béchamel.
And it was almost like
butterless béchamel.
And it doesn't goop up.
And it was the most--
and he makes a
seafood stew with it.
And I was at dinner
in State Bird one day.
And I was telling
Stuart about it.
And then he said,
oh, I was in Padu.
And they make the same thing.
And they do it in the Andes.
And they make a
chicken stew with that.
And so I am still trying to--
I don't want to share that yet.
But I'll share it
in the next book.
But it was going
to be in this book.
And so there is a lot of--
what shaped it, I
always thought I
was going to separate
it by [INAUDIBLE]
the parts of the classic
Japanese meal and not
by regionality.
But also, because I wrote
a section on history,
because Japan's got a lot
of homogeneity nowadays.
And a lot of the food
here is coming from,
I mean, from all over Japan.
But it was very
difficult to separate.
The history is pretty
amazing in that there's
these food cultures and
the method of making rice,
not rice cooker rice
but real rice in a pot,
and glutenous rice
that's been around
for hundreds if not
1,000 years the same way.
And if you are American,
this is an astounding idea,
because we have such
a young country.
But sorry, I got off track.
Yeah.
So the shaping, it
became a much better book
because of the issue
about the no photos.
So it took shape for different
reasons, as it should have.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
I was wondering if you
can talk a bit more
about your first book.
And just what was the process
for you getting a publisher
and just even getting
into the cookbook writing
industry in the first place?
NANCY HACHISU: Well, I started
probably 10 years before that.
I got involved in
slow food for myself.
But also, I live in a little
town and 15,000 people,
it's not so little, in Japan.
And I wanted to get more
into the world of food.
And through that process--
and every time I went out to
dinner in Italy or France,
I'd hand my card to
the-- at that time,
it was my slow food card.
We were really into cards.
And so I just carded
people up everywhere.
And then I just
sort of went along.
I became friends with some
people at Chez Panisse.
So we started this exchange
with a soba chef friend,
going to do dinners
at Chez Panisse.
And then it was through slow
food that I started writing.
And because we
did a soba dinner,
and I told my slow
food friends, do
you guys want to write
an article about this?
And they said, yeah.
We're going to send the
photographer and the editor.
But we can't afford a writer.
So can you write it?
And so I wrote this long
thing, which was way too long.
And in the process, I realized--
and then I handed it off.
And then I also wrote about
the edible school yard.
And I realized that they
were just going to--
it's just a pain to
translate, to actually do
a good translation.
So my editor friend
just read what
I wrote, took all of my
ideas, and wrote his own thing
in Japanese.
Like, well, that's no fun.
And so that's when I started,
OK, I knew it was way too long.
I knew it wasn't
the right format.
And so I started doing
the online classes
through Stanford.
And then somebody
said, start a blog.
And so some of those stories
in "Japanese Farm Food"
I had written in a blog,
and then the blog camp.
And then Michael Ruhlman,
who's a very prolific author,
he suggested I get
involved in this IACP.
And then I took my
son to Portland.
We went there.
And he ended up in
school in Portland.
And I went to this--
I put myself in the position
of being in sessions
where there was an agent.
And I just asked the
pointed questions
that we learn how to do
in high school and college
to say, look at me.
I'm just so smart.
So I would drop the Chez
Panisse thing and the living
in Japan thing.
And so she contacted
me and said,
what are these ideas you have?
And of course, card, card, card.
And it's too bad
that the cards are
going on the wayside with
non-Japanese countries.
But I got some cards
with me if you want.
But one of the boxes
was for a chiropractor.
It was like, they
sent me two boxes.
And one's wrong.
But anyway--
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, I just opened it today.
And then I wrote a proposal.
And actually, I
got lots of passes.
And then Andrews
McMeel accepted it.
And then that's the way it was.
But you got to write a proposal.
AUDIENCE: What is Chez Panisse?
NANCY HACHISU: Chez Panisse?
It's a restaurant in Berkeley.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
NANCY HACHISU: Probably the
mother of farm to table.
AUDIENCE: One of the things
I find very interesting
is you have a foot both in
the Northern California food
scene and the Japanese scene.
And you mentioned your roots
in the slow food movement
and the farm to table movement.
That's obviously very big
in Northern California
and as a response to the
industrial food system.
Can you talk a little bit about
how Japanese culture approaches
food and what the differences
are you see between the way
Japanese approach
food and the way
you see it in, say,
Northern California?
NANCY HACHISU: Well you know
I'm not the know all for Japan.
I have my take.
So Japanese are very accepting
of the poor ingredients.
Even mothers, they
don't read the back
of what's in the label.
And if somebody
made it for us, it
must be good is a really
big overall feeling.
And again, I don't want
to be madly generalizing.
But I do have a
little preschool.
And I have lived
there for 30 years.
And this has been
a huge experience.
That even strawberries
that are sprayed
with chemicals 30
times, and they're still
giving them to the kids.
I mean, I finally had to say--
occasionally we have
bento in our school.
Mostly I cook.
And I just finally
just told them,
could you just please don't
give those strawberries
to your kids?
Like all over the world,
people are cooking less.
In Japan, they went
from big farm kitchens
to this crappy little strip
in some corner of the house.
And there's no room.
It's a lot harder to cook.
It's harder to
buy the materials.
I ask people all the time, we
have a local soy sauce and miso
place that also makes tofu
and tofu-related products,
natto and some of the [? age. ?]
Whenever some media comes,
I always ask them, so on
your way home from work,
can you get good natto?
Or can you get good tofu?
And these are the
instant foods of Japan.
I use them at the school when
I have nothing else to cook,
except for dry
pasta, which I hate.
Then I can do a
tofu lunch thing.
And they don't have
access to good ones,
because those kind of
things are less and less.
But it's resurging.
And that is thanks to,
OK, the hippie movement
and then also from
you guys, actually.
It's the great
thing about Japan.
They look to the other
countries, and they'd see.
It's the reverse
importation or exportation.
I can never remember
which is the correct word.
And long term foreigners,
why am I on TV?
It's not because I'm
so scintillating.
It's because I have
been there a long time.
I make my own miso.
I do these things.
I live in an old house.
But also, I can say, hey, this
katsuobushi is so amazing.
And so it's like this, oh,
yeah, maybe it is cool.
And they just never
thought about it.
Most people don't even know
the difference between Kikkoman
and our soy sauce, Yamaki Jozo.
They don't know that it's made
with Chinese non-organic beans.
And this one over here
is Japanese organic
aged in cedar barrels
for a year and a half.
And this has been made in a--
or actually, these
are not even Kikkoman.
The cheap stuff is made
from soybean grits.
It's not even beans.
So people just don't know that.
Even TV directors come,
and I take them to Yamaki,
and they don't even know the
difference between miso and soy
sauce.
So it's starting.
And it really helps.
Everything that you
guys do comes back.
So it really helps that the
whole world is foodifying.
The bad thing that
happens in Japan,
unfortunately, is
everybody seems
like they're obsessive about
food, like watching, or the TV.
I mean, I don't know how
many people still watch
TV, but still a lot of people.
But what happens is I
think they get intimidated.
And the katsuobushi guy
told me six years ago
that 60% of the
people who make dashi,
which is this simple kelp
and dried fish broth, not
like chicken stock that
takes an hour and a half
or two hours and bones,
and 60% of the people
that actually make
it, use powdered.
And I think that's because,
it's not the convenience thing,
I think it's from
intimidation of,
oh, there's this Kyoto chef.
And he's using maguro bushi.
And he's doing this,
and this, and this.
It's the most amazing
dashi in the world.
I can't make that.
So I better just get powder.
I feel like it's like that.
And so there's that
having to have perfection.
I know my rolled egg
omelet is not as beautiful
as my husband's.
I can live with that.
But it's delicious, because we
have good eggs, and good soy
sauce, and good [INAUDIBLE].
And you have to forgive
yourself I think.
AUDIENCE: I know you're doing
some collaborative dinners.
You've already done
some or you're going to.
I think that's very
exciting for me,
because I'd like
to attend and go.
What's it like for you, because
these are chefs in restaurants?
I mean, what's it like for you
to do a collaborative dinner?
NANCY HACHISU:
Everyone is different.
And it starts with the approach.
Mostly, nobody says
no, surprisingly maybe
because it was such
a direct approach.
The "Japanese Farm Food"
and also the preserving book
are both really popular
with a lot of the chefs.
And I write the menu or
don't write the menu.
I sort of feel my way through
with each different chef,
and some of them I know,
especially the first time.
And then sometimes they're busy.
Actually, this tour I ended
up writing a lot of the menu,
because there's 400.
I kept whittling it down.
OK, here's my top 100.
Here's my top 50.
And then, OK, can you just
write the menu, Nancy?
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
Some of them are
part of the menu.
And then there's
all kinds of things.
I'm in the kitchen all day.
So why not?
And I just sort of feel my way.
And it's harder for the
first time collabos.
I bring all of the materials.
And so this time I could
only bring 50 kilos.
That was sort of my max max.
And Hodo Soy, I got
hooked up with their sales
guy in Natural Expo last year
or a year and a half ago.
He didn't know anything
about my books.
But some of his
people were big fans.
But he was just a fun guy.
He's this six foot tall,
wearing shorts, ponytail guy.
And so I just loved him.
And so I really wanted
to promote Hodo,
because they're local.
And I had to get over the fact
that it's not Japanese tofu.
And so he gave me yuba to taste.
And then when I came back last
fall, he gave me soy milk.
And he sent it and medium tofu.
And then I found a way.
The medium tofu for Hodo,
because they don't use nigari.
They use a Chinese sodium
chloride or something,
some other harder--
so [INAUDIBLE]..
But it's great for chefs if
you put it in the Robot Coupe.
And you don't have to press it.
And the flavor is good.
So anyway, and then the
Japanese Pantry guys donated.
So it's all about the materials.
And I don't want to have a--
I only collaborate
with people who
have the same ideas as I do.
So I typically don't collaborate
with Japanese restaurants,
because they have a budget.
And they're using less than.
And so here I just bring it
all and say, let's use this.
And I give them their budget.
And that's it.
I mean, their budgeted
amount of stuff.
And there was one
other thing I forgot.
Oh, I'll be chef at residence at
Scribe over Labor Day weekend.
Come, come, come.
And I was going to
do it last October.
But because of the
fires, we canceled.
So you guys look like
Scribe people, right?
No?
[LAUGHTER]
All the beautiful people.
I'm going to be one too.
Yay.
Anyway, I think all the collabos
in the Bay Area are over.
I'm going to be at Omnivore.
But you'll just hear
the same thing as here.
Not really.
But I'm going to New York.
SPEAKER: All right.
Thank you very much, Nancy.
NANCY HACHISU: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you
for being here.
NANCY HACHISU: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]